so i'm going to write down a number and
i'm going to think about how much do
each of these digits of the number what
value do they represent and actually let
me pick on this 2 here what does that 2
represent does it just represent two or
does it represent something different
than just two pause the video and think
about that
all right now let's think about it
together and actually i'm going to start
with the seven here the seven is in the
ones place so this seven represents
seven ones which is of course still just
seven so nothing too surprising there
then we could go to the tens place
so this one doesn't just represent one
it represents one
or another way to think about it it
represents 10
and then this 2 it is in the hundreds
place so it doesn't just represent 2 it
represents 2 hundreds
we could write it that way or it
represents the value 200. so the number
here is 217.
the 2 represents 200s or 200. now let me
give you a slightly different question
i'm going to write down
three numbers
so
we have this number and i'm
intentionally not saying it out loud
that number
i have this number
and i have this number
and what i want you to do is pause the
video and tell me in which of these
three numbers does the 7
represent
70
pause the video and think about that
all right now let's work through this
together
so let's start with this top number
this in this number the seven is in the
ones place so that seven really just
represents seven ones which is still
just seven
so this seven does not represent 70. now
this next number the 2 is in the ones
place
and we see that the 7 is in the tens
place
so this actually represents 7
tens
well
7
tens
is the same thing as
70.
so it's actually in this second
situation
where the 7 does represent 70. this
number is 572
the 7 represents 70. and let's just
check this last number here
well here the 7 is not in the ones place
not in the tens place it is in the
hundreds place
so this represents 7 hundreds or 700 and
that makes sense this number here is
705.